ya no son Bienvenidos en túnez Así que
decidieron marcharse de madrugada estos
145 marfileños toman el avión hacia
billán tras el repentino endurecimiento
de la política migratoria de túnez
muchos subsaharianos indocumentados
Perdieron su trabajo y casa un clima
pesado se ha instalado en el país y los
ataques racistas se han multiplicado
empujando estos africanos occidentales a
hacer las maletas
lo dejé todo atrás y solo me llevé esta
guitarra como recuerdo soy estudiante
estoy en situación legal pero al ver
todas estas injusticias tuve que volver
un poco difícil
no esperábamos esto no estábamos
preparado para esto así que duele pero
estamos muy contentos de volver a
nuestra patria que nos acoge con los
brazos abiertos
esto porque en marcha una ayuda
económica para sus nacionales expulsados
de túnez 500 personas se han suscrito a
este programa de ayuda a los repatriados
los inmigrantes irregulares han recibido
fuertes multas de las autoridades
tunecinas sanciones de hasta 1000 euros
al mes que impiden a muchos de ellos
poder pagar un pasaje de vuelta
túnez se ha convertido en una cárcel al
aire libre para nosotros los subsarianos
por ello los países de origen han tenido
que organizarse para permitir a sus
ciudadanos salir del país después de
Guinea y Costa de Marfil la junta
maliense fletó el sábado un avión con
150 pasajeros con destino a babaco a
principios de año había 21.000 migrantes
subsaharianos registrados en túnez es
decir menos del 0,2% de la población